hey guys
welcome to another episode of
congratulations
crazy
[Music]
it's another episode it's another
episode of congratulations and um
[Music]
you know we got it up we got it all dude
we got it all in life don't we we got it
all you just got to realize it that's
why i say life rips man
a lot of people write in to me about uh
the hard times that they're going
through and life is as good as you make
it and you can just basically have no
limbs and still have life be ripping
it's all about a mentality baby and
that's why uh you know
oh by the way that's why we got these
here life rips these are new the new
colorway on the [ __ ] um podcast go to
chrisley.com and you know it's like yeah
life rips but also i gotta collect racks
so it's like that's that's what it is
um so yeah it's like oh his message is
also collecting racks but it's like any
message collects racks right
so it's a movement yada yada people get
tattoos it's a yada yada it's a cult
yada yada and it's all good but uh you
know that's how we do it
gotta come clean my babies gotta come
clean dude and i'll tell you why dude
and i'll tell you why and you don't even
know you don't even understand uh
what i'm about to say but
last
time i
had a uh
podcast episode of congratulations i uh
we had a conversation me and won fire
and kristen afterwards and we were
talking about how carhartt was the new
von dutch
about how von dutch was firing on all
syllables for a while killing it
[ __ ] absolutely changing the game and
then all of a sudden paris hilton wore
the [ __ ] and then it [ __ ] petered out
now it's not parasite's fault is van
dutch's fault but then carhartt became
that [ __ ] right carhartt was
pretty cool all the kid hit kids were
wearing it and all the [ __ ] um
guys were wearing those orange beanies
with the car hard shits or if you're a
king in the sting fan you absolutely
wear car heart right because there's no
such thing as a king in the sting fan
that doesn't have at least two three
articles of car clothing okay
and they've got that real industrial
ship but this not because they're
hipsters it's because they do real
industrial [ __ ] and they're in
pittsburgh
right
um but i was like man i can't believe
how i got out of the [ __ ] carhartt
thing without even doing it because i
thought i felt the carhartt pull
i felt the pull and now it's getting a
little bit overboard with the hipsters
in los angeles with the twisty mustaches
wearing a [ __ ] carhartt industrial
cargo pants right or a nice flannel
that's bulky and [ __ ] like they even
wear gloves in the wintertime
and i was like i got out of it without
wearing it and then i looked in my
closet today and boy oh boy dude did i
forget about ordering a car hard thing
a few months ago and i'm wearing it
right now and i never [ __ ] wore it
because i have to expose myself because
i gotta come clean my babies
[Music]
i'm i'm you know am i hipster am i
industrial you do the math dude i'm a
little bit im you right i'm that
industrial hipster that's what i am
and uh and i feel a little bit phony but
dude i completely forgot about having
the car hard shard i really forgot about
it so anyway
that's it dude i had to come clean
um we got to tell the truth here we got
to [ __ ] talk about the real
hard-hitting issues and you don't know
me
if you don't know me right and i have to
let you know me i started this whole
podcast because i still wanted to
[ __ ] uh uh
i was a little bit trepidatious and
starting the podcast if you if you
listen to the first or second episode
ever i talk about how you know i don't
really want you to know who i am i don't
really want because i still want to do
roles as an as an artist as an actor and
[ __ ] i mean how the [ __ ] can i daniel
day lewis head up
right if you guys know all about my [ __ ]
like i'm i'm exposing myself about
carhartt
but [ __ ] you don't know what daniel
day-lewis is really like you don't know
what leonardo dicaprio really is like
besides the fact that he like you know
wants to save the ocean or whatever
but you don't know if i want to [ __ ]
i didn't want you to know if i
i didn't want you to know if i wanted to
save the ocean or not when i started
this podcast
and now you're now you know every all
the [ __ ] ins and outs about me dude
i mean i've cried on this podcast
multiple franken times
sad all good though we persevere
we get through it right because life
rips you collect bags or you don't you
have limbs or you don't you get cans or
you don't but life rips i mean everybody
gets cancer right
just depends on when you get it
hopefully you're getting it at like 80
something or even 90.
but my point is
now you know me
oopsie daisy
whoopsy daisy was it by design no
but it was my destiny wasn't it
it was right do you believe in destiny
or not is it a bunch of malarkey i don't
know
when somebody comes up to me and they
say do you believe in fate
i go like this dude i don't really
talk or think about that man you got the
wrong guy don't you
guess how many times in my life i've
thought about fate honestly give it a
good hard long thought fate destiny
guess how many times in my life
well if you're an avid listener you
probably get zero and you'd be right
because that's the whole thing
is it by design
life or
is choice something
and my whole [ __ ] is
who [ __ ] cares we're never gonna know
oh yeah but those are the earth's
unanswered questions
don't you want to know why we're here
what's the meaning of life when somebody
says what's the meaning of life i think
but what do you mean
the meaning of life is whatever you want
it to be isn't it
a lot of parents will say the meaning of
life is about being a parent
i love my son i love my daughter but bro
the meaning of life could be about i
mean as ben and jerry it might be ice
cream dude and if that's the meaning of
life for them then that's the meaning of
[ __ ] life so stop asking me what the
meaning of life is if we're just having
a conversation
because it's whatever you [ __ ] make
it dude is fate real i don't know is
destiny real i don't know is choice real
maybe feels like i'm choosing doesn't it
when i look at two pair of shoes and i
wear one i chose that one didn't i
so i don't get heady and uh i don't get
you know
i don't get too
right i don't get to you know what i'm
talking about in my [ __ ]
in my in my in my head right
but sometimes we start the podcast and
we're talking about real hard hitting
issues
you know some things in life make you
sit back and they make you think about
it
like i did the road technically it was
an arrow away oxnard i did improv levity
live
and uh it was the first time i actually
did quote unquote the road it's a little
bit funny to call oxnard the road when
you live in la but it is they get comics
from all over the place uh los angeles
you know but also new york and boston
and chicago or where the [ __ ] lives
wherever i don't know tennessee
um
and i i i accepted a weekend you know
they reached out and i said yeah um but
you know if you know if you want to go
on the more chris
uh more crystallia channel you can see
the the vlog there that we did we had a
lot of and friends which were uh king
batch trevor wallace uh brendan shaw
brian callan and um michael lanochi
and uh maddie chimber which is a new
comedian that's very funny you should
check him out but we did that in oxnard
california and it was awesome um we had
a really great time but i'll tell you
man driving down there we got this van
and everybody piled in we made a [ __ ]
thing of it it was like 11 people in the
van kristen was there too
kristen even brought her mom one of the
shows
um and uh
it was uh
you know i got in the van
got to the oc got to the place oxnard
went into the green room
and boy was it a mixed bag of emotions
man
i don't like when people say stuff like
that but it really was
it was like a bag that i put all my
emotions in
and i could look inside of it and think
huh look at all those emotions
but instead of looking it was feeling
right
i just wanted to cinch it up but i
couldn't man it was like it was
overflowing like i i was a little bit
excited but also thinking i wonder what
it'll be like right
like two years ago when i would [ __ ]
just dang it
on the road just binky
right
i just do [ __ ] madison and then
milwaukee and chicago and
right
uh this was a one-off i was gonna be
there do five shows and that's it and um
i was uh going to
the show and it was exciting i got to
the green room and immediately i felt
this overwhelming sadness and i don't
know what it was
i don't know what it was but i was
excited i saw the green room and then it
was like wow
it was like you were transported back
now i know the last time i did the road
was about two years ago but it was like
i was transported back to
legitimately my
my mother would like hold me and tell me
it's okay or some [ __ ]
it was back when like
i was transported back to another time
it was like a past life
i mean look i'm still a comedian i do
shows at the laugh factory that improv
all the time but
this was the road technically
and i was in the green room
and
the whole crowd was just waiting for me
to go on but i'm a different i'm a
different man now like my son
is a huge part of my life i don't live
with the doors closed anymore i live
with them open
and that's what this whole mixed bags of
emotion was because
i was feeling everything and it was
[ __ ] insane man
it was vivid i was happy and sad and all
of it right
and kristen showed up with her mom
supporting me and uh
you know my my real homies were there
and it was
a lot i don't even really know how to
describe it i'm trying here
each friend would go up and go on stage
and it felt good
it felt good the applause they got
everyone was having a great time in the
audience the comedians all killed
and then i went on and the first show i
went on was a
friday early show
and i went on and it was amazing and as
soon as i got out there
i've they started cheering you know
loudly for a long time
some bragging i don't mean to brag but
this is what happened and
i felt behind my face just swell up
and i'm like for [ __ ] sake you know
you get that little taste of copper in
the back of your [ __ ] mouth
and you're like am i gonna [ __ ] is
this gonna am i gonna start my eyes
gonna cascade what the [ __ ]
am i gonna turn into a japanimation
character what the [ __ ] is going on
i let it subside with the crowd and i
did my act
and about
you know i did 35 40 minutes about 25 20
minutes into my act
i started talking about my son and
i [ __ ] couldn't help but god damn it
i started crying man
and it just came out and i said god damn
it i get to this part and i start crying
and everyone was cool with it
and
it felt nice to be vulnerable to a bunch
of people
and
it felt
natural too which is the weirdest part
because all of the stuff
that i've been thinking about and doing
in the past
year and a half or whatever with my
family and myself and just other people
like the walls down
[ __ ] feels like it's working because
when i'm on stage and i can be
vulnerable like that
i mean it is a far cry from the guy who
started this podcast
that didn't want to
have anyone know who he was
but it's because
if i'm honest
i don't think i
wanted to know who i was
i don't think
you know i talked about this a little
bit in my act but this business they
just [ __ ] reward you for things
when you're hot
and it's easy to just lose
to that
as a weak person or as a person with
moments of weakness you know
so it's interesting this
journey is another word i don't like
because it's like
seems pretentious but it's what it is
right
and everyone's got their own [ __ ]
and for the people that came out
to my show
um thank you for coming
i normally start this podcast off
ripping and roaring but
i don't know i didn't want to or i
thought i wanted to
but it didn't happen just like when i
thought i wanted to start the podcast
and keep you at arm's length
that didn't happen either
i i was with uh
the other night
i started doing
my group therapy i was on zoom and i i
said goodnight to calvin and he was
really [ __ ] tired and i could tell by
the time i got out of my group therapy
he was gonna be asleep i got out at nine
and i knew he was gonna be asleep and i
got out
and i walked upstairs and i noticed on
the on the that calvin's door is open
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on and i
go into my bedroom and he's there with
kristin and he's saying
and he's in his sleep sack and chris
said he was just up he was staying up
for an hour and he wasn't even uh he
wasn't even um
going to sleep he was just sitting up in
his crib uh and so
and so he was sucking his thumb holding
the back of his head which he always
does and tarzan is blaring i mean phil
collins is just like even when he's
[ __ ] swinging through vines
whatever the [ __ ] he's singing you know
um
he's got the line cloth carefully placed
over him when he's swinging through the
vines why don't we show his [ __ ]
his [ __ ] would be flailing around
from trunk to trunk we would be showing
his trunk but we're not
[Music]
because this is disney
or whatever the [ __ ]
you're telling me that when he never
climbs
he doesn't scrape the [ __ ] out of his
[ __ ]
come on
that loincloth isn't even tired
understand
it's just carefully tied around his
waist
i mean come on you can't even [ __ ]
have a rope tied unless it's doubly tied
without it opening up and exposing your
card
tarzan should have
so in conclusion
tizen should have a scrapey dick
right but it's covered right because
it's disney right
[Laughter]
the biggest [ __ ] in the disney
family is
doesn't have a screen pdf
[Laughter]
so anyway dude
um
so anyway where he's there and [ __ ]
tarzan's just swinging around with his
loin cloth around how do you even get it
there's just bananas and coconuts and
apes how do you even get it
does he sew
with what
hey tarzan nice to meet you where's your
scrapey dick
right
so um even the monkeys are like
where's the scrapey dick right
so he meets [ __ ] so he's doing it and
i and i say what the f i say what the
[ __ ] kristen and she says he was up he
wouldn't go to bed so i brought him in
here we're watching tarzan
and he looks and calvin goes
looks at me looks back to tarzan all
eyes on tarzan dude my son loves him
from tarzan and secretly i was hoping he
was going to point to tarzan and say dad
died because you know tarzan's buff and
he's got long hair and i was like maybe
my son sees me like that
he didn't do it for a while but he ended
up doing it he ended up pointing to it
and saying dada
so that made me feel good and that's the
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] i am a 41
year old that has a [ __ ] two-year-old
son that gets happy when he points to
tarzan and says da da because then i
secretly think well maybe my son thinks
i'm buff
got probs
so anyway um
we're watching the thing and calvin's
got a bowl of [ __ ] pretzels do it and
he's just housing a man i mean he's just
like a [ __ ] tree trimmer just
just housing him he's got two three in
his hands and his little [ __ ] hands
and i was like what are you watching and
he and he points
and he ate all the [ __ ] pretzels in
the bowl dude
right and kristen had chinese food like
a [ __ ] piggy that she ordered while i
was doing my [ __ ] group therapy
and it was just the whole room stunk
like [ __ ] right because of the chinese
food when someone brings chinese food in
and you're not hungry game over dude if
you're in a [ __ ] house and somebody
and you just ate and somebody brings
chinese food over uninvite that
[ __ ]
oh it stinks to high hell huh you know
how rude it is to
bro that's like one time i was on a
plane and somebody brought popeyes on
the plane and just started eating this
[ __ ] and it was like cool i'd rather go
down
and it was a lady so you can't say
anything you know if it's a dude maybe
you just give them a look or you'll be
like ah bro really
you're gonna eat a [ __ ] six piece on
on the way to tucson
so um
so he's watching the thing and he's
eating the
pretzels finishes the pretzels and
kristen does the most [ __ ]
uh
what like the most like
dick [ __ ] the most like this is what she
does she says you want more pretzels and
he says yes
and she says
oh really well do you want dada to go
get you more pretzels and now i'm like
it's all on my son
my laziness rides on my son
right
because if kristen was like hey can you
go get pretzels for me i could reply
with
your legs don't work
but she's asking me in front of my blood
she's asking me in front of my son and
if i disobey kristen
in front of my son
he grows up
and he [ __ ] up life
i'm trying to limit those i don't want
my son to be a chippendales dancer right
i don't want my son to hold up banks
so now she
hits me
well through calvin secretly hits me
with the hey calvin do you want do you
want dad dad to go get pretzels oh and
my son knows those words
so i'm sitting waiting dude
waiting for my son to answer and he
looks into my eyes
past my face and says yes
well i guess i'm moving
ain't that just like life man
you used my son
to thwart my laziness unfucking
believable dude
kristen
unbelievable you used my son to thwart
my laziness
so i get up and i say sure and guess
what i'm [ __ ] happy about it that's
the most annoying part because i love my
son yes
[Music]
so i'm going downstairs i fill it up
with pretzels and i dude this is how
good of a dad i am i don't even do it
with one version of pretzels we got
three versions of pretzels i had the
twisty shits the stick shits and the
pretzel chips bro i put them all in like
like it was [ __ ] cereal dude i put
them all in the bowl like it was my
emotions in oxnard dude and i brought it
upstairs and i'm mumbling well i'm not
mumbling but i might as well be because
in my head i'm thinking i'm a [ __ ]
jeep yeah guys i'm one pretzel well i'm
a [ __ ] dad and went down and you
fought my laziness and we got three
[ __ ] different things
so i bring them up dude you know you
when you're riding with a certain type
of [ __ ] when you're riding when you're
snacking when you're out there and
you're snacking maybe you're watching
shark tank but you're out there snacking
and you know you're riding with a
certain type of chip what are you gonna
do you're gonna remain with that chip
aren't you right you got sour cream and
onion and then you got [ __ ] mesquite
flavor and then you got pretzels if
you're [ __ ] with sour cream and onion
that bag is gonna be empty before you
even touch mesquite [ __ ] before you even
breathe on the pretzels and my son was
rocking with the twisty shits well i
brought the twisty shits i brought the
sticks up and the pretzel chips bro we
got it all
and i give it to him and i think i
wonder he was gonna do like that that
does and only rock with the twisty shits
and sure enough he only rocked with the
twisty shits
but then kristen told me something that
was so [ __ ] cute when i got there he
said she said i can't believe what he
just did i said what and she said
and she said
halfway in the middle of while you were
there he looked at me with his palms up
and he goes tada
like he was [ __ ] impatient dude hey
man you don't even really know how time
works okay
you haven't even lived two years dude
i've waited for [ __ ] longer than you've
been alive
and this guy's pissed off with how long
i'm taking dude don't go palms up to
dada
oh dude you go palms up
you're not a bad kid
you're a good boy
just maybe figure out how time works
before you go palms up with dada that's
all
bro it was hilarious dada and then he
goes and takes two and [ __ ] didn't
eat the chips or this or the sticks just
the just the twisty shits
so he rides like dada with the chips
uh
and it was cute then we watched [ __ ]
uh tarzan and for a little bit and i oh
dude and then i was getting so tired
and she put calvin to bed in the in his
in his crib and then i was so tired dude
and i started falling asleep and god
damn it dude why
why i get i wonder if you does this
happen to you guys too
do you have like a a a girlfriend or a
wife or a fiance or whatever the [ __ ]
you got and you live with someone and
you're [ __ ] sleeping it's like 10 30
p.m right and you're falling asleep and
they [ __ ] wait hey stay do you want
to get ready for bed hey
i skipped that part
and then you're just like guess i'll be
up for another three and a half hours
dude i skipped the part
what the [ __ ] is go what what what are
you all how come you're all
chronological now when i'm sleeping
what are we doing i just lived a [ __ ]
i'm doing i'm my day was like a quentin
tarantino movie it was all out of order
and now you're like
trying to [ __ ] assemble it and sell
it in a disc set like it's a crew like
it's a [ __ ] something they're trying
to push on christmas and when they did
that with the godfather it was like you
can now own the godfather in
chronological order and my dad
scooped it up quicker than bad dude he
was in line waiting it waiting outside
of best buy just like
dude he watched this he watches the
godfather always after christmas and he
just [ __ ] he couldn't wait till that
dvd came out it was like nine dvds dude
remember when [ __ ] was nine dvds long
dude just put it on one goddamn thing
and now it's not even physical it's not
even tangible
but god when that chronological [ __ ]
godfather came out my dad was bowed
about it dude
so i'm like you you want me to get all
[ __ ] chronological i'm sleeping
already and she's like
oh i don't know
you know and then and then it's like you
can't get mad
oh cause oh you didn't know
and then no matter what you say you're
the bad guy how do you not know i'm
sleeping well i just thought maybe i
don't know because your eyes you take a
contact or maybe you have to or you know
you're just like yeah yeah
yeah you win once again
you win once again ma'am
so i'm now i get now i'm trying to sleep
and i'm but i'm pissed you know the
heat's rising in my chest and so i'm
like okay well [ __ ] [ __ ] man
you know you made me get up and get the
pretzels
you [ __ ] combated my laziness through
my son and now i'm sitting here [ __ ]
i did the thing and now i'm falling
asleep and you want me to wake up to go
to sleep
so now i'm just [ __ ] in the back and
now i'm my the heat's rising right my
heart's getting full but not with love
so
i'm like going i go to the bathroom i
get ready i brush my teeth i take my
[ __ ] contacts out
and then i come back i go to and juji's
watch and i'm she's watching something
on world war ii
and i'm
and so and now i'm going to sleep i'm
trying to fall asleep again and i can't
do it and i didn't go to sleep till like
2 a.m isn't that great and that [ __ ]
great dude
so
i finally fell asleep and i [ __ ] dude
i got so and boy and the boy and also
the boy's office gabapentin the boy's
off zany island i don't even [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] anymore i was on it i and
people would talk like oh you take z you
do xanax be careful dude i never i don't
do that [ __ ] i just did it every now and
then
right
to quell my [ __ ] to try and [ __ ] calm
me down but i don't do that anymore and
and if you notice on this podcast i
could i don't reach for words gabapentin
would [ __ ] cloud my [ __ ] up
i don't reach for words at all dude
i probably couldn't have got that word
chronological a minute ago if i if i was
on my gabapentin
so yeah man but that was so funny with
calvin and the pretzels about how he
asked for where the [ __ ] that that is
dude as a dad you don't give a [ __ ]
that's the thing like as a kid remember
when you were a kid and you would do
something and your mom would be like wow
i'm that's at least you know i had a
good family so my mom would that is very
wow look at what you did and you're just
like huh
i'm [ __ ] ten i put on my shirt you
you know
i lifted up a [ __ ]
like a
like a [ __ ] jug of milk like what why
no i am proud of you you figured out to
put that top on all by yourself and
you're like
mom
like i opened up a bank account [ __ ]
a week ago i know how to do this [ __ ]
but like and you and and now that you're
the dad you're like
oh isn't it cute he said where's dad
that cause he was impatient for the
[ __ ] pretzels
it's crazy how much life changes and i
used to hate that [ __ ] dude
when i was 16 my [ __ ] girlfriend
broke my heart started dating my friend
and that was the moment that i started
listening to tupac and dude if you
thought i was raw in 2017
[Music]
you thought i was raw in 2017 bro i
ain't got no [ __ ]
[ __ ] man in [ __ ] tooth in
1996 forget it dude
i was annoying you [ __ ]
one time my uncle said who do you think
did more for america tupac or abe
lincoln and without without
hesitation i said tupac and my uncle
laughed like
hell
he left so hard i was 16. he asked me in
the middle of me
boxing a punching bag
sir
la canada
um
but yeah
it is what it is
[ __ ] man
how about [ __ ] uh
pitbull doing this tweet i don't know if
it went viral or not did it
it did go viral oh wow okay
hey pitbull what's going on
god damn it
pitbull tweeted this thing monday
motivation so people are confused by
this
not just us okay so he it's a picture of
him
staring out of a window pensive
like he's up to something
and it says you don't make mistakes
mistakes make you first of all makes no
sense that makes no sense right
no you make mistakes you don't get to
rearrange the english language to your
liking
yeah right it's not even your first
language what are you trying to do here
is it pitbull from somewhere else
and like you're just coming in here
you're like no no listen dude you put
mistakes
mistakes make you you know that right
anyway
here's my hit kulo
um doesn't kulo mean [ __ ] by the way in
[ __ ]
anyway here's my hit [ __ ]
anyway
this is my hit single snatch
anyway dude
yeah dude you don't make mistakes
mistakes makes you anyway here's my new
here's my new [ __ ] here's my new
single
fried butterfly here we go
it means ass okay cool well
either way kulo means ass
here's my here's my you don't make
mistakes mistakes make you anyway here's
my new hit single [ __ ]
um
so it says you don't make mistakes
mistakes make you therefore
like a shakespeare dude remember when
you were writing an essay in high school
and you needed to do it past a certain
[ __ ] amount of word count and you'd
just [ __ ] therefore and however it up
you'd even throw a lass in there like
you're a like your name's [ __ ] like
your cyrano de berger what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] bergerac the siri no [ __ ] god
damn it there what's that i don't that's
not even because of gabapentin i'm just
a stupid [ __ ]
cyrano how about that dude
and uh he says therefore dude in a
[ __ ] essay therefore however alas
um
he says you don't make mistakes mistakes
make you therefore they're must takes
what does it mean though
god imagine
here's all you have to do is to realize
how [ __ ]
insanely insanely stupid that is
imagine
you're hanging out with your friends
and he's kind of the guy that's like
right here like not in the circle but
also listening
and then he throws that in
how much would that ruin the goddamn
time
you'd be like yeah man let's go over
there
hey you know you don't make mistakes
mistakes make you therefore they're must
takes and you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
that's cool
what does it mean though
must
i i asked juan fire i was like what does
it what does must takes mean and he was
like i don't
because they're saying mistakes make you
maybe it's like you the you and must
hates and i was just like
that's what he means and then i was like
is it must takes
also
what
must takes like you must take something
like his [ __ ] social media guy was
like okay cool yeah i'll do that ah
also one of the rare times his
sunglasses aren't on so you know he
thought it was deep as [ __ ] because i've
never seen pitbull's eyes
also monday
motivation imagine seeing that and being
like cool gotta get after it
unreal
made a song called kulo
i love that [ __ ] dude that's hilarious
hey man don't be inspirational if you
made a song about an [ __ ]
imagine being [ __ ] pitbull's dad and
you just no matter what he said you were
like oh yeah but that you made a song
about an ass
although my son will be i mean jesus
christ all the [ __ ] i've said on this
podcast
um
[ __ ] unreal dude cool
[Music]
people are absolutely insane
how about that guy who [ __ ] stands
dude i have a friend that does that that
just is right there all the time you
know he's one of those friends
everyone has that friend if if you don't
you should too cause this dude's a
down-ass homie let me tell you about
this down-ass homie that everybody
should have in their friend in their
friend group because this [ __ ]
is a down-ass homie
like i'll cry this dude will cry with me
but he is always this is how this dude
is he's a really close friend of mine
and this is how he is i always think
whenever we're out or we're with people
or we're at one of my shows i always
think say his name i don't want to out
him but say his name is steve i'll be
like where's steve and
halfway through
his name i go
oh right he's right
there
that's a down-ass homie the guy that's
just kind of lurking and [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is oh yeah of course
that guy's a down-ass homie
um
but yeah the uh
yeah he came to oxnard and i was like oh
okay he's right there
i can't by the way
every now and then life throws you
something or the world
the world throws you something that you
swear was a thing already because it was
so goddamn obvious
and you were like
and you're like oh this stuff i've never
you ever
um
hold on let me you ever you ever like
see something an ad for something or an
invention or a show or something and
it's like oh but that was already oh
and they're and they're like hey this is
new and you're like no it's not new this
has been around and you're like oh i
guess i just never [ __ ]
it just seems like such an idea that
would have been around that that that
now it's around and you're like no i
knew that and like am i psychic dude the
[ __ ] judge steve harvey the fact that
that hasn't been a thing from
1999 on is unreal
as a matter of fact how did steve harvey
get a daytime talk show before he was a
judge on a [ __ ] show
dude
judge steve harvey
how is that honestly
how are those judge shows like those
guys all make nine billion dollars a
year what's her name [ __ ] judge judy
you have a job no get one remember that
commercial
[Laughter]
dude it would be on the radio when you
were going to school you'd be like judge
judy kcal9 kcalcal9 i can't tell not
judge judy you have a jab no
get one the no is always off mike cause
the [ __ ] guy didn't know where to
stand cause he was just a civilian not
an entertainer
dude judge judy was the she's still
alive right she's
the biggest [ __ ] and i'm at dude
here's something that judge judy you
know is true about judge judy if you
[ __ ] were invited to her house for
dinner she you would walk away thinking
well that was the most pleasant lady
i've ever met
you'd be walking home with [ __ ] like god
damn she really with the green beans and
they were better than i thought
i didn't know i liked green bean
casserole turns out judge judy cooks up
mean dash
got a job no
no this is what it was like dude you
have a job
no
get one
and dude it was bro that was the clip
they'd use for the radio my god and you
just be like this [ __ ] [ __ ] is she
even a real judge
now you're gonna give dude how do these
[ __ ] how does it work you get
it no you're wrong you're gonna give him
900 thanks case closed
what
i don't even have a job get one
and that other one math judge mathis
that guy
the face
on that guy the matter of fact dude the
face on that guy was so
so
if you looked up the term over it like
if you google
over it
mathis is probably on the third row just
a bunch of pics of him just like
mm-hmm
bro it's hilarious that steve r steve
harvey just watching mathis
after he would get home from his daytime
talk show just watching matthew just
fuming knowing like yeah but no i could
do this better and now he's got the show
and steve harvey goes like this oh you
think that face was the face for this no
no
i mean steve harvey's face steve harvey
literally looks like someone is wearing
steve harvey's face
that guy's unreal
it i mean dude i've been canceled [ __ ]
it i could say this but like he he he
his face literally you you literally
look at his face and you think am i
racist like that's how much his face is
his face
and then this guy saw judge mathis and
he was like nah
not that oh you think you're over it
judge matthews was like this steve
harvey's gonna be like this
the most over it [ __ ] ever dude
i mean for [ __ ] sake dude
ah sorry i need to take a pee pee break
uh but i'm back and if you're listening
you had no clue and i just i just
exposed myself so uh not expose myself
in the peepee way but expose myself in
the it doesn't matter anyway um yeah
what do you call it uh
i was watching about how the the [ __ ]
uh how
what's his name uh
[ __ ] the
rapper uh uh mgk machine gun kelly
uh
was trying to ask uh megan fox to marry
him and uh i looked at that and when he
dressed like beetlejuice and he did it
that's hilarious he was like or or was
somebody put the meme up when the
footlight is like when the foot locker
uh gets down on your on their knee to
put their their shoe on you your shoe on
you i mean i'm butchering it but that's
just hilarious like what are you what
are you doing wearing white and black
stripes what are the hamburglar um
and uh
and so
um
they uh
he gave her a ring and it looked nice
enough sure of course and then they're
talking about how i think i
megan fox's engagement ring
is designed to hurt her if she takes it
off and it's like dude
it's supposed to be difficult to [ __ ]
take off
it's supposed to have thorns in it
thorns quote unquote
let's look at this let's look at the
let's lift this up megan fox ring
bro that's so
i know it's i know it's
for the shock value and [ __ ] and like
for it's a it's real love but like it's
also scentsy you know what i mean like
you're not going anywhere like it's so
something in that would have that would
start doing in 1980s that just we missed
and machine gun kelly is doing it and
like it's also so something that if i
did it would have backfired and people
would have called me out on it they
would have been like oh really she can't
go in how much are [ __ ] how much are
russians looking at this and they're
just like i can't believe he figured
this out we never got to do this
we we own our women i don't understand
how stupid wafey white or american
rapper figure out how to do this with
supermartial actors
i want to put on my girl now people are
going to think i copy
michigan kelly says mega fox's
engagement ring was designed to hurt her
if she takes it off
well he's just like yeah this way i
didn't have to have a gun
this way i didn't have to threaten her
um
this [ __ ] what is this from people
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude the bands are
actually thorns machine guilty to vogue
of new fiancee megan fox you need custom
two-stone engagement ring
the bloody valentine musician equipped
what about love is pain
what is this [ __ ] about blood and like
pain with love like love is just love
people are just like love is pain
yeah
the [ __ ] what's it what's his name
billy bob
thornton and angelina jolie wearing each
other's blood around their neck it's
like what just love each just cuddle
nah but it's blood to show the token of
that no just cuddle
instead of that just hold each other's
hands yeah but i love her okay
yeah but i want to show the world that k
take a picture put it on instagram
imagine if you just oh what's that in
your purse oh that's my boyfriend's
liver what the [ __ ] yeah i love them i
want people to know when i take out a
tip when i take out and put a tip for
the waiter i want them to see his liver
in my purse because i want the world to
know that i love my boyfriend in the
meantime the boyfriend's in the car just
bleeding out
spitting up blood
but do you love me
clear
oh i see the problem man you kept his
liver
like how do you like what the [ __ ]
why didn't you just cuddle with him
i did it to show his love i'm sorry
blood
like
could have aids in it
you're playing basketball with it on it
[ __ ] breaks and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude
i gotta tell the guy who was guarding me
he might have hiv uh
insane
blood
i never thought blood was sexy at all
some people think blood is [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's like
ser the chicks who think that serial
killers are hot ooh
they joke around about that no you don't
dude your dad didn't die laterally get
out of here
yeah but ted bun are you kidding me dude
yeah but have you seen the pictures of
ted bundy dude if ted bundy was in a
room
with [ __ ]
you know
you'd be like what is what get away
what is he charismatic for a serial
killer you're not thinking further far
enough
it's like when it's like when uh [ __ ]
uh chicks it's like when like they're
like oh yeah well
it's like you know what it's like when
[ __ ] what was his name uh
john hamm was in bridesmaids
and people are like well he was [ __ ]
fun the movie was funny
oh yeah john hamm is funny he's fine
dude
he's he yeah he's he's
fine
put [ __ ] nor macdonald in it
he's funny
chris farley i'm just saying dead guys
but there it's like dude oh yeah john
ham
out of here he's funny for the way he
looks yeah okay think it through then
get further
he's playing ymca basketball with a
bunch of [ __ ] other fat guys that's
what it is
he's not patrick god damn ewing
um
so yeah
all right we're gonna do some
misconnections and here's the deal dude
i had somebody write in on the patreon
can you explain to viewers what missed
connections are before jumping in still
kind of confused and all that now don't
want to say
figure it out or think further but i
will
i understand okay this is what miss
connections is first of all it is time
for miss connections
and um because i do that because i'm a
talk show host right worst job ever
to be a talk show host and so um but uh
miss connections are some it's something
on craigslist that people go to
yes lonely people as a matter of fact if
you're on craigslist you're lonely
period i don't care if you're looking
for a [ __ ] microwave
you're looking for something to fill
that hole aren't you
so misconnections is when if i go out
and i see somebody
at the [ __ ] home goods
and i'm picking up something from my
home goods [ __ ]
and i go i'm waiting in line and i
notice a lady that's kind of staring at
me but i'm too bitched to say anything
and then i grab whatever the [ __ ] i got
like some you know some nice fancy balls
i want to put under my
tv or right in front of that as a
centerpiece to the you know some ceramic
balls you can get those at home goods
who the [ __ ] going to home goods
really just people who are bored out of
their goddamn minds right
like what's at home like people women
are walking out with homegoes like a
[ __ ] with like a straw witch
you know yeah but i want to put it on my
out out near my house
oh okay
you're just buying things you're just
[ __ ] taking
things that are in a place and putting
them in another place
you don't really have it you die
and it's just gonna you just transferred
it and you paid to do it anyway
you're leaving home goods and with the
straw witch and ceramic balls
and you and you're too [ __ ] to say
somebody
say something to somebody else who you
think is attractive and they're holding
their own straw witch and ceramic balls
and you go into your [ __ ] key and you
drive home to your one bedroom apartment
and you're lonely right
you're setting up your balls and you're
lonely as [ __ ]
and you got your straw witch and you put
it there you're like you know it'll be
nice
to look at this thing that i transferred
from one place to another
with someone else
so they know that that i transferred it
i want to share this experience of
transferring these [ __ ] ceramic balls
into my one bedroom apartment from this
goddamn warehouse that took my money i
want to share that experience i want to
watch those ceramic balls with someone
else
and then you think oh yeah that lady
that lady in home goods that i was too
[ __ ] about to talk to
we had surrounded
i could have struck up a conversation i
could have said hey lady
you're a fan of ceramic balls and straw
witches too
and the love could have blossomed and we
could have had a child that re that we
raised
in this beautiful well decked out
ceramic balled up straw witch to one
bedroom apartment and we're gonna raid
raise this child and this child could
have
grown up and we could have taught him
[ __ ] and there could have been so much
love in our family and then one day
this kid could grow up to go to a
different own goods
and get [ __ ]
his own ceramic balls with straw witches
and met another person
what could have done that but i missed
the moment
i didn't connect with the lady with the
ceramic balls in the straw witch so
i'm now on this lonely site called
craigslist
and maybe she's here too
and you sit and you write
wittier home goods
and the subject that's the subject in
the body you write
you had long brown hair were holding
ceramic balls
and a straw witch
i was too lol
looking
to see if you're here because i'd like
to meet you and that's how you connect
because she happens to be on the website
too
now i don't know who does pr for this
[ __ ] i don't know anybody who does
pr for this [ __ ] besides me here on
this congratulations podcast
i don't know if it works i'm sure it's
worked in the past but that's what miss
connections is
it's a thing on excuse me while i
[ __ ] throw up almost but it's the
thing on
craigslist that you can go to a section
and here is the first entry that we are
going to talk about this week
ellie culver city hey ellie let's
celebrate the long weekend send a pic or
name of club and valley you would go so
i know it's you
lonely
hey guy
text her oh you don't have her number
ah
sir
one bedroom apartment
not knocking it
lonely
here's the next one today is when this
one's just smooth it's called that's the
subject
today is wednesday i like how he starts
off [ __ ] punctual like that going to
go home after work and shave my whole
body smooth putting on some makeup and
getting all dolled up for top masculine
men only
looking like a latina tonight
wow
looking like a latina tonight that's
like the [ __ ] can you get canceled
for just being on craigslist
you can't do that [ __ ] that's cultural
appropriation what if the guy showed up
with a [ __ ] rock hard [ __ ] and he was
just like wait what him wait a minute
are you latino no but i'm looking like
it that's cultural appropriation and he
walked away with this [ __ ] rock hard
[ __ ]
here's another one lost keys is the
subject here we go lost my keys if
anyone found a set of keys please
respond wow guy doesn't really
understand the [ __ ]
doesn't really understand the idea of
missed connections
lost keys
wow what a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] ones
huh
wow one fire is getting a [ __ ] one
fire for those three
those are about some keys looking like a
latina and then a guy's just looking for
his friend ellie at least i described
miss connections well so now you know
what the [ __ ] it is
um
what
there's more
there's not more wow [ __ ] bad job
dude
oh said i thought there was more dude
worst [ __ ] guy at his job
all good dude oh good that's good for
now man what'd we do an hour
did we do an hour we did an hour right
dude i love you guys man thanks for
listening to my my podcast and i'll tell
you this much man we started off on an
emotional journey and i appreciate you
letting me do that i usually [ __ ]
just hit hard and swoop down like a
[ __ ] phoenix right and i give
it to you bang bang bang before i ease
back
before i ease back take the
take the foot off the ped a little bit
and just start coasting and telling you
some nice stories but this time what i
do
i kind of [ __ ] took my time
accelerating right and that's okay
because this podcast is fly by the seat
of our pants
i wrote down four topics and i [ __ ] i
think i own
what what is it
one more misconnection there is
and so [ __ ] fired
i don't oh you found another one right
now is what you're saying
them oh my
god here's another one here's the
subject the mexican i met in the park
it's racist dude in bushwick ridgewood
made a place um you are a mexican macho
wow
this is for sure from a fat short bald
guy
and we met while smoking a large cigar
in maria hernandez park i am the white
boy very submissive and i worshiped your
[ __ ] in my house
wow dude
i want to do it again i want to be your
[ __ ] yeah well that was obvious when
you said you worshipped his [ __ ] in your
house
oh my god dude do not contact me with
something
services or offers it says
another one
oh yeah that was a good one for sure
dude unreal um
remember do you remember when i
worshipped your [ __ ] in my house
one of that reminds me of the thing i
used to know a dude who used to say
every time he get he would get mad at
somebody he would [ __ ] like one of
his friends he would be talking about it
with his other friends and he was one of
those guys dude he would do this all the
time he'd be like you don't understand
man this [ __ ] i invite him into
my home it's like dude what the [ __ ] bro
who do you think you are
this guy comes into my home i break
bread with this [ __ ] like dude
shut the [ __ ] up
i invite him into i invite you into my
home he get mad i invite you into my
home like his home with some [ __ ]
palace who gives a [ __ ]
you guys seen too many movies
anyway dude crucillia.com
for that merch that's the new colorway
with the blue life rips killing it and
we got them hats too we go crazy on
those [ __ ] hey guys that's it
for this episode of congratulations if
you want to catch the rest of the
episode uh the uncut version not the
youtube version the patreon version you
go on over to our patreon.com crystallia
it is always longer and more uncut no
youtube ads uh and uh it's six dollars a
month we also have other segments that
we do that we put on there and um we
have behind the scenes footage from like
my road dates and [ __ ] like that but you
can get all the content there
patreon.comcrystalia
go now and if you don't it's all good
we appreciate you
[Music]
uh
thank you
[Music]
hi